today's draft the top trade candidates
for 2020. chris you have the trivia
question that is always determines the
first pick yep there's no way you're
going to get this today so just guys put
it on there right now cam newton will be
my first pick cam newton will be my
first pick here we go greg olsen signed
the seahawks yesterday as you know back
in 2011 olson was traded by the bears
stupidly by the bears i don't know why
they traded him he was true because mike
martz doesn't use tight ends is that the
answer i win
yeah
was traded by the bears to the panthers
for a third round pick the bears then
package that pick to acquire what pro
bowl wide receiver i even gave you a
help there
with the pro bowl wide receiver see you
you've set me up by making it seem like
it's really hard in two thousand so hard
pro bowl wide receiver is are you are
you are you being serious uh i am pro
bowl wide receiver san antonio homes no
you're just like the vikings quarterback
you can't deliver in big moments you're
just like them geez gosh you said it not
me you're horrible i can't brandon
marshall brandon marshall remember that
brandon marshall well done yeah yeah i
should remember that all right guys cam
newton cam newton pick number one of
course i'm going cam newton i mean first
off the guy's a handsome guy and that
was a lot there's there's a few crazy
outfits we just showed in that matchup
but a lot of them are really good
outfits i mean i don't know if i can
pull off the hat but i like the outfits
but the man but he can pull it off he
can because he is like a statue come to
life he can pull it off he's a greek god
he is i mean he's a defense and playing
quarterback in the nfl and he is uh
awesome football player i say to anybody
who acquires cam newton's talents at
some point yeah you got a chance to win
every game uh when he's on the field
when number one's on the field you got a
chance to win a football game he is a
phenomenal football player and yes i
think with the panthers and matt rule
and joe brady and the new era in the
carolina i don't think he's going to be
one we want to be a part of that
completely and i don't think necessarily
they're going to really want him either
i think they're going to want their own
fresh start and not having a guy part of
the old regime being such a huge focal
point in the locker room i think they
will look to trade him and i'm with you
i think it's the chargers but i think
cam newton is certainly the leader of
this list
the wild card in all of this is whether
to what extent cam newton is going to
want a franchise quarterback contract at
19.1 million in total compensation for
2020 he is at the low end of the veteran
needs more
second contract market so it's going to
be more is it 25 to 30 is it more than
30 he's gonna have to show he's healthy
and you know what it may just be a
short-term contract or almost like a
deal like the one drew brees signed with
the saints initially had a payment for
2006 and then a significant option bonus
the following year that the saints would
not have picked up if drew brees ended
up being not effective after having 26
studs in his shoulder from the injury he
suffered in his last game with the
charges i'm gonna go andy dalton right
and look it may be that at the end of
the day the bengals have to just cut him
or maybe just keep him but at only 17
million dollars unless dalton is going
to be jostling for a new deal that's a
very tradable contract
of guys on their second deals it's cam
newton and it's andy dalton at the
bottom of the barrel and i think someone
when the dust begins to settle is gonna
want andy dalton who knows maybe he'll
be somebody's plan a right out of the
gates right let's just get this done
let's get andy dalton at 17 million so
we don't have to get into this this
crazy bidding war that's going to be 25
30 million plus per year let's get andy
dalton let's have him for a year and
then let's move forward i still think
there's a chance that bengals keep him
yeah depending upon what their draft
plan is uh but uh you know the longer
they hold on to him the harder it's
going to be to get good value yeah i
mean i i'm with you i mean i think andy
dalton you know whether he's signed to
be you know traded to be that like
bridge quarterback for somebody maybe he
ends up in carolina after they trade
away cam newton and they go okay we know
we're going to take a quarterback but
let's have a veteran guy in here who you
know we don't need to have the
quarterback be the guy right away in
year one i could see something like that
happen i could also see a team like the
chicago bears going let's bring him in
for 17 million let's do it we're still
paying mitchell trubisky rookie contract
money and if trubisky gets a lot for a
backup it is a lot a lot i think you
always say you have a total number for
the position
and you know trubisky i think is one of
those guys that we got to put on alert
right now if they get off to a two and
two start and he's played horrible
football you know that would be the time
you'd go you know i think we need to put
andy dalton in or something like peter
king peter king has mentioned andy
dalton to the patriots so many times and
it it made me think he knows something
he claims he doesn't i know but he
mentioned all to the patriots any time
the topic comes up yeah i uh and and you
know i mean i don't know if brady's not
there i don't know if that's a crazy
thought either that's what i mean he
could be the bridge guy for where they
think stidham might take over a few
years who knows but okay um my next one
i'm going aj green
aj green cincinnati bengals like you
know you've heard me talk about the
bengals and the rebranding and all that
andy dalton this sounds like he's going
to be out the door like the bengals just
need to fresh new fresh start you know
and you know joe burrow into town just
bringing a whole new crop of young
receivers with him and let them flourish
and grow together you know i don't
necessarily always think it's a great
thing for a young quarterback to
um
come in and then have a presence like an
aj green in the huddle and you know
who's gonna want the ball it almost puts
more pressure on the young quarterback a
lot like cam newton and steve smith
senior right that type of thing that's
all i'm saying there now i know
that right now aj green is poised to be
a free agent but i would have a hard
time thinking they're just going to let
him get out the door free here i would
think that at the very least they
franchise tag them tag and trade
trade right and i just think yes that
there's going to be a market for aj
green whether it's the patriots the
packers somebody i would think is going
to call him because i still think
there's a lot of tread left on that tire
or or tag and keep and then trade him
during the season if the bengals end up
struggling
getting more immediate value when you
can hey if muhammad sunu was worth a two
last year what's aj greenworth if he's
available at the trade deadline this
year so yes i agree with you there all
right next with me is le'veon bell they
almost traded him in 2019 right before
the trade deadline he came out and said
it was the chiefs it was the texans it
was the packers it was the steelers who
were in on the action and they they
ultimately didn't do a trade because
le'veon bell was unwilling to adjust his
contract he's due to make 13.5 million
this year fully guaranteed hey that's
not more than what the much more than
what the steelers paid him three years
ago under the franchise tag i wouldn't
be stunned if the steelers bring him
home i really wouldn't be i wouldn't
either and i i you know i i think that
some of these other teams we've we've
already mused about the possibility of
the chiefs upgrading their running game
with le'veon bell for this year can you
imagine le'veon bell in that offense my
god just give him the trophy now
it would be amazing it really would and
i'm with you i think the steelers if
this comes down to it will be the to be
a team that is very much involved in the
conversation for le'veon bell but yeah
i'm interested to see i mean i think the
jets you know i'm not going to pick this
guy with my next pick but i'll throw it
out there maybe you end up using them i
mean the jets le'veon bell and jamal
adams i think they're both guys that i'd
say watch out for you know i don't know
necessarily if i'm like convinced that
the jets are in love with jamal adams i
don't know if they want to deal with it
i i don't know i just i have no inside
knowledge there i think jamal adams is
arguably the best safety in football i
want to make that clearer but you know
as we've seen he's he's a personality
he's loud he wears his heart on his
sleeve and that can rub coaches and gm's
the wrong way at times but that's not my
pick my pick is trent williams trump
williams washington redskins i still no
bruce allen's gone he's going to stay
you think so for sure
yes yes okay fine then i'll take that's
my guess
jamal adams anyway but i think i think
they're trying to mend the fences there
i think they want him to stay and i
think the fact that bruce allen's gone
and they made other changes could be
just what it takes to get trent williams
to decide i think i want my trent
williams pick still i still think he's
gonna get traded i think it's over
i don't think he's gonna want to be a
part of it i just think it's over i'm
still staying with trent lamb screw you
you're not scaring me off my picks trey
williams
all right i i was thinking about taking
david johnson we've addressed his
situation 10.2 million fully guaranteed
i think there could be a trade market
maybe to a team like the buccaneers and
bruce arians who was the coach of the
cardinals when johnson was drafted but
you either have to send the whole
contract with a draft pick like the
texans did when they unloaded brock
osweiler's deal on the browns three
years ago or you're going to have to pay
some of the money to get the bucks to
take on that contract for this year
either way it's not going to be a trade
where there's a significant amount of
value flowing to the cardinals and the
cardinals if they've got the cap space
they may as well just keep the guy
around because maybe second year and
cliff kingsbury's offense will really
take off especially if they aren't able
to keep kenyan drake so my pick is sammy
watkins and i i know that you know the
chiefs are saying they want to work it
out they want to keep them around and
it's important to have him but it's a
huge salary obligation this year 13
million plus and it may be that they use
the possibility of trading him to
another team to get him to take less to
stay you never know what's going to be
that factor that gets a guy to say okay
i'll cut it from 13 down to nine or
something like that uh because look he
he has been an important part of the
offense but he's not worth 13 million
plus based upon his production
and and uh you know at some point you
got to trust the young guys you got to
you got to hope me cole hardman who
basically was a no-show in the super
bowl you got to hope nicole hardman
second year in the system could maybe
become what sammy watkins was for a lot
less money than what they'll be paying
watkins so i could see him get traded to
a team like the packers yeah chris
wouldn't that be so wouldn't you love to
have sammy watkins play with your guy
aaron rodgers no doubt about it i i do i
mean i think he yes you know them you
know again the new england patriots they
could all be interested in a guy like
sammy watkins for a one-year type deal
that way whatever it may be you know he
still got talent as we saw i mean you
know that was one of the biggest plays
of the game him beating uh
richard sherman off the ball on that
second touchdown drive there in the
fourth quarter that ultimately put the
chiefs up ahead but you're right and the
chiefs too with michael hartman tyree
kill they've shown the affinity to have
a very good eye for the wide receiver
position talent-wise as far as giraffe
and yeah sammy watkins number as far as
what he's getting paid does not match
the production certainly who else did
you think about on this list like i had
oj howard on here um i put him as i
mentioned i talked about jamal adams
i'll tell you the other one i had on the
list mike and this is from your team
that's why i'm bringing it up stefan
diggs i just wonder there you know had
somebody tell me earlier that he's wiped
away maybe some of his minnesota stuff
on social media his instagram page or
something like that look he he could be
a little temperamental and i love him
we've had him at super bowl which is one
of our one of our favorites
i didn't get the vibe when we were with
him that he's detaching emotionally or
mentally from the vikings but you know
he's going to keep his cards close to
the vest but
they're not using him the way they could
or should in light of what they're
paying him they're paying big money to
adam feeling big money stefan diggs if
you're not going to use those guys
you're better off moving on from one of
them and saving the cap dollars that
they're going to need for other
positions so that one doesn't that one
doesn't stun me if it happens i'm not
going to be shocked at all and you know
there's always been that that notion
that he could end up back in washington
uh a kind of a hometown team he went to
school with maryland and and anytime
this bubbles up it's that washington
connection and maybe with ron rivera
there they they make the move to try to
bring him to dc all right we got to take
a break quick recap sims has cam newton
aj green and then jamal adams no trent
williams no jamal adams no finally he
settled on trent williams i get andy
dalton le'veon bell and sammy watkins to
the green bay packers playing with oh
aaron rodgers we got to take a break
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports